the government being
subject to suffrage
creates the notion aha
here's how we're gonna we have to seize
this state
and then the the
that gets agreed upon but there's a big
split as to how to do it
one side says
you go with the election you you you
mobilize the voter that gets to be
called reformism within marxism and the
other side is revolution
don't do that this system if i may quote
bernie again is rigged
uh you can't get there
they've long ago learned how to
manipulate
parliaments they buy the politicians and
all that
and therefore revolution is going to be
the way to do it revolution
gets a very big boost because the
russians they did it that way
they didn't do i mean they fought in the
doom
in the parliament but
they didn't and that this focus on the
state i would argue
goes way beyond what the debaters at the
time
and if you're interested in the great
names
there was a great theorist of the
the role of the state in a reformist
strategy to get power uh in germany
named edward bernstein very important
his opponents in germany
were karl kautzke and rosa luxemburg the
two other huge figures in marxism at the
time and
they wrote the articles that everybody
reads but it was a much broader uh
debate and by the way that debate still
goes on
reformism versus revolution
and in in terms not all that different i
mean it's adjusted to history but in
terms of different can you comment uh on
where you
lean in terms of
the mechanism of progress
reformation versus i'd rather tell you
the historical sure
over and over and over again in most
cases the reformists have always won
because revolution is frightening is
scary is dangerous
um
and so most of the time when you get to
the point where it's even a relevant
discussion not an abstract thing for
conferences but a real
strategic issue
the reformists have won i mean and
i'll give you an example from the united
states in the great depression of the
1930s
you had an extraordinary shift to the
left in the united states the greatest
shift to the left in the country's
history before or since nothing like it
suddenly
you created a vast
left-wing
composed of the labor movement
which went crazy in the 19th hour we
organized more people into unions in the
1930s than at any time before or anytime
since it is the explosion and at the
same time the explosion of two socialist
parties and the communist party that
became very powerful and they all worked
together creating
a very powerful leftist
presence in this country
they debated in a strategically real way
reform or revolution
the reformers were the union people by
and large and the the communists were
the revolutionaries by and large because
they were affiliated with the communist
international with russia and all of
that and in between you might say that
the two socialist parties one that was
trotskyist and inspiration and the other
one more
moderate western european kind of
socialism and they had this intense
debate
and they ended up the reformists won
that debate there was no revolution in
the 1930s here
uh but there was
a reform that achieved unspeakably great
successes
which is why it was as strong and
remains as strong as it does because it
achieved in in a few years in the 1930s
starting around 1932-3
social security in this country we had
never had that before it's the same one
we have now
unemployment insurance never existed
before that you have until today
minimum wage for the first time still
have that today
and a federal program of employment that
hired 15 million people
i mean these were unspeakable gifts if
you like to the working class so that's
the 30s and the 40s 30s very much in the
40s anymore but in the 30s and here's
the best part
it was paid for by taxes on corporations
and the rich
so when people today say well you can
entice the government the joke is i have
to teach american history to americans
uh because it has been erased from
consciousness
you